la section des crimes majeurs a déployé
des experts qui possèdent un vaste
expérience en enquête complexe la GRC du
Manitoba a aussi déployé des enquêteurs
chargés de la reconstruction des
collisions des experts en
identité judicale et nous travaillons de
près avec d'autres experts comme le
bureau du médecin légiste sur place
un grave accident donc cet après-midi au
Manitoba 15 morts et 10 blessés graves
qui ont été transportés dans différents
hôpitaux de la région notamment à
Winnipeg c'est un camion semi-remorque
collision avec une camionnette qui
transportait principalement des aînés
alors je disais quinze décès dix autres
blessés on connaît pas encore l'état de
santé de ces blessés je rejoins Pierre
Bellemare ancien policier de la SQ
spécialisée dans la reconstitution de
scènes de collision merci de nous
monsieur Belmar
alors la GRC déclenché évidemment une
enquête
qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on arrive sur
les lieux d'un tel accident qu'on veut
en connaître les explications les causes
je suis allé voir sur Google Maps pour
voir l'endroit où c'est arrivé et je me
suis informé auprès de vos gens savoir
quel était la provenance de chacun des
véhicules alors on avait le véhicule qui
était Cameron remorque qui se coulait
sur l'autoroute et que lui normalement
c'est circule en ligne droite il y a pas
d'arrêt obligatoire à faire il y avait
aucune raison d'arrêter sur les lieux
contrairement à la cohésion qui était
survenue les joueurs de hockey là
c'était c'était un petit peu différent
mais similaire et là vous aviez le
véhicule des personnes âgées qui lui
devait céder le passage du candidation
lui était en direction
sud et puis le verset de passage au
cameramorques puis vraisemblablement
surtout vraisemblance c'est lui qui n'a
pas se défendre le passage un impact est
survenu par le maire sur le coin côté
latéral droit du véhicule et le véhicule
a pris feu et ça ça me rappelle une
question qu'on avait au lac Bouchette
est-ce que je disais de faire votre
recherche on avait eu 18 mois au Québec
dans différents
où les gens avaient été pris à
l'intérieur du véhicule il y avait pas
été capable de
s'excirper du véhicule en raison des
flammes et puis ces gens-là étaient
décédés pas nécessairement de l'impact
mais était membre libre tout simplement
c'est un peu probablement ce qui est
arrivé à cet endroit-là mais ce qu'on va
valider c'est la provenance des
véhicules on va regarder les dommages
parce que naturellement on va tout de
suite constater que lequel des deux que
possédait le passage parce que ça semble
invraisemblable c'est un des deux
véhicules qu'on va se dépasser
93 donc au lac Bouchet vous avez
travaillé sur cette tragédie alors ça va
rappeler de très tristes souvenirs à
bien des gens qui qui ont vécu cet
événement là mais on sait au moins que
les deux conducteurs sont vivants déjà
là ce sont les premières personnes qu'on
pourra interroger si leur état de santé
le permet
vers l'arrière du véhicule que vers le
devant et donc la force d'impact était
plus où la majorité la majorité des gens
étaient immobiles assis à l'intérieur du
véhicule on sait eux puis on voit
d'ailleurs le camion les images que vous
montrez présentement que le devant du
camion qui est notre état est tourné
vers la droite qui nous montre que le
véhicule a passé devant et lui
probablement voulu donner un coup de
roue vers la droite pour l'éviter et
avec la force de l'impact ça confirme la
provenance des véhicules et
le véhicule malheureusement pour des
raisons pour l'instant qui sont
inconnues ici le divin tant mieux ils
vont prendre donner des circonstances
que un malaise des choses comme ça pour
ne pas se dépassage au véhicules c'est
ce qu'on verra avec l'enquête votre
rassemblement parce que c'est justement
comme le conducteurs sont vivants ils
vont donner leur version mais ça peut
être une simple distraction ça peut être
malaise ça peut être il y a plusieurs
circonstances
j'ai l'impression qu'on voit ça va être
un facteur humain on va vraiment s'en
aller parce que c'est probablement qui
véhicule sur la bonne condition
l'environnement visibilité était bonne
etc alors je pense qu'on va se rattacher
à des conditions humaines
distractions malaise je pense qu'on se
dirige dans ses
fonds
étaient défectueux ça peut être aussi
une autre cause mais on cherche toutes
les causes on met toutes les options sur
la table
toutes les actions sont sur la table
même si complètement brûlé je suis
persuadé qu'on va vérifier certaines
composantes des freins est-ce que les
freins étaient est-ce qu'on avait la
capacité de freiner on va sûrement être
capable d'aller chercher quelques
informations à ce niveau-là au niveau de
l'inspection mécanique du véhicule au
niveau du freinage par exemple et s'il y
a des gens l'intérieur du véhicule qui
sont conscients autre col constituants
ces gens-là vont interroger rencontrer
pour leur donner la version des faits
puis le chauffage du camion aussi qui a
vu responsablement arrivé le camion aura
des choses à dire intéressantes par
rapport à la vitesse à laquelle notre
véhicule là il est parti d'un arrêt ce
qui est passé complètement tout droit
c'est des éléments intéressants qui va
falloir approfondir et en même temps ça
implique combien d'enquêteurs ou
d'inspecteur quelle est la démarche ça
peut prendre ça peut être long mais
juste on peut penser qu'il va avoir une
enquête du coronaire dans
l'examen de la 5 on va faire relever ta
peau de la scène au complet on va
immobiliser les véhicules on va faire
une vérification sur tous les véhicules
on va regarder ces véhicules là ont des
modules de contrôle qui pourraient nous
donner de l'information et après ça il y
a toute l'enquête au niveau de la
rencontre des gens qui va se faire dans
les prochains jours et naturellement les
reconnaissions de la GRC sont présents
sur les lieux certainement que plusieurs
personnes on a parlé d'identité
également qui vont qui sont là pour
éventuellement aller chercher le plus
d'informations possible mais
naturellement ça va prendre plusieurs
jours plusieurs semaines voire
probablement avant qu'on ait les fameux
de la chose très bien Monsieur Pierre
Bellemare ancien policier de la sortie
du Québec et spécialisée dans la
reconstitution de drame comme celui-là
merci beaucoup de votre expertise et de
l'avoir partagé avec nous ce soir au
revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI